one thing that i did is i went back kind
of with fresh eyes after i had watched a
lot of these long-form interviews with
tate and a lot of this extensive content
i kind of went back with fresh eyes and
looked at some of the shorter clips with
with those eyes
um and i found a few that i said you
know what i could see these triggering
the right people but there's a lot of
unpopular truth in them
um there's a lot of humor and i want to
play them um these exist you know as
these short videos that he doesn't love
but i noticed a lot of things in them
that i didn't see the first time around
so let's do you have these tyler the
first one is on tick tock this is um
we'll run this up to 18 seconds let's
just take a listen
so that you could have multiple partners
but a female that was with you couldn't
also have multiple partners well a woman
could say that same thing if she decided
she could say i can sleep with multiple
men but my men can't sleep with multiple
women if she's so choose we're all free
individuals right yeah but you don't you
wouldn't agree if a woman said that i
would personally find that revolting
correct but there are women who find
what i say revolting
so even just that
right
i mean the lead-in is him just saying
well yeah but if you're a woman you're
in a relationship but you decide that
you want to make that decision you can
go make that decision i personally find
it this way but you might find it you
know what i'm saying it just seems very
i'm just i don't see the outrage now of
course if you listen to the whole thing
he goes on to give his opinion on it
which people have a problem with but i
wound up finding a lot of this nuance in
there that i hadn't heard before now
maybe i didn't hear it because it wasn't
clipped in the actual videos that i was
watching that part was missing maybe i
didn't hear it because i got stuck on
the second part and wasn't paying
attention before because i didn't allow
for that proper context
but i think it's really interesting i
know if you want to respond to that one
or hear a few more there's several of
these that have the same theme um but do
you think there are a lot of people out
there i guess is a great question for
you who
had been inclined to disagree had kind
of made up their mind a little bit about
him
went back after this looked at some
extra content and said well wait maybe
i've been played a bit here i would say
very few
if that um i think you and i had this
conversation when i first came in there
yeah
um you know like when you begin an uh an
argument or begin a quote-unquote debate
with like i have not seen very much of
fresh and fit but let me explain to you
exactly what's going on with fresh and
fit right and so when i because i know
i've been part of that show for almost
two years now
i know what's going on behind the scenes
i know who these guys personally are and
everything else and so i'm just like you
know what if you just go and you educate
yourself you take the time it's what i
call intellectual lethargy and that's
what most people
are about because again we're in the
tldr generation the tick tock video the
45 second hell i i put out like uh every
occasionally i put out a short vid a
short form video that's maybe 54 seconds
and i can tell if the person even
watched the 54 second video right
because what most what most guys do is
they'll look at the title right they'll
look at the thumb they'll look at the
first two or three comments and they'll
go screw this guy you know it's like
what i call a drive-by comment right and
then they never watched it and i can
tell they didn't watch it because their
comment reflects that they didn't even
watch the whole thing or else i'll have
guys who'll go hey where's the the link
to the whole video it's at the end of
every clip it's at the end of every
every short the you didn't take the 54
seconds to get to the end where that
link is right there so clearly you don't
have an investment enough to really want
to you just want to feel heard you just
want to like i think that's probably
what a lot of guys and women as well
want to uh they they just want to have a
take they want to have a hot take they
want to believe that somebody out there
gives a [ __ ] about their about what they
say
comment right and so that's that by the
way that's very powerful because people
want that engagement and you can use
that to your advantage if you know how
to how to use it however
do people go back and they actually look
at the the video do they go to watch a
two-hour video to see uh did the
freshman fit really get owned by
brittany renner no they didn't but you
gotta you have to invest two hours of
your time to realize that it was a
really good conversation it was a really
good debate but if all you're looking at
is 45 seconds of man she really owned
those guys and that's what you want to
see and that's what your opinion is of
andrew tate or myself or fresh and fit
if that's what you want to see that's
going to reinforce that 45 seconds that
you took you to watch that video that's
going to reinforce your estimate and
disqualification of anything that they
have to say in the future as a result of
that so do people actually see this and
go what's he really talking about here
like the same people are talking like
this girl who's on on the show here
talking about like well how can you say
that men can cheat and women can't and
and he just said you can do it too it's
like that's the you know he's trying to
express that you're not going to get
that part you're only going to get the
hot take of him saying well a high value
man should should be able to cheat and
his woman should not be able to cheat
he's just saying he he's explaining it
to you but you have to go and look watch
the long form to get the full picture of
what he's saying and in the meantime the
same people who are having a problem
with him say that are the ones who want
to be in a poly relationship in a
throuple
you know right this exactly
here it is yeah but you can't say it the
other way around yeah
all right let's play the second one
tyler you have that one
we have a few of these they're great
i'm not saying that i'm sad yeah i'm
saying in general in general if every
man was honest with himself if you were
to ask him what's the worst driving
you've ever seen what's the most
uncomfortable you've ever been in the
car what's the worst parking you've ever
seen what if you were to ask him and he
was honest and he wasn't on the internet
worried about getting cancelled or
trying to be correct or looking up
statistics or any dumb [ __ ] he'd
probably say i was in the car with this
chick once and she nearly killed me that
is not saying women are bad creatures
i'm not saying all women drive that way
it doesn't mean that i don't think
females should have a right to drive etc
so even that you know it was interesting
because there's a lot of caveats that
he's throwing in there he is he's saying
i'm not saying women are bad i'm not
saying all women are bad drivers i'm not
saying x y z i'm just saying if you
asked a bunch of guys i happen to think
that's 100 true if you asked you know if
you go to my husband and you say who's
the better driver in your house he's
going to say i am she drives like maniac
he's going to say it and sometimes i do
drive him like a maniac and i think
that's again it's like an inconvenient
truth here you know not to even
unflatter in terms of unflattering yes
it's not i um
let me let me let me let me break this
down for you i forget again i'm going to
give you a quote and i forget who said
this okay
uh to to create or is it uh it is an
order of magnitude greater
to
refute [ __ ] than it is to create
[ __ ] okay yeah it takes you 30
seconds to create [ __ ] it takes you
two hours to refute that [ __ ] that
was the 30-second buzz clip right okay
so and i i want to say maybe it was ben
shapiro somebody who said that but it's
an order of magnitude greater to refute
[ __ ] than it is to create [ __ ]
and that's what he's he's kind of
dealing with here because what happens
and i'm i'm guilty of this too and so is
myron and fresh because when that clip
came out uh hassan who i think is like
the co co-host or a good friend of like
ethan klein on age three started going
well you know insurance rates this and
let me show you why you know women are
better drier they're safer drivers right
and it's like that's not what he said he
said men are better drivers didn't say
they were safer drivers and so what
happens you got these you got me you got
myer and you got god knows how many
other people who are going and they're
going and doing the research and saying
okay here's why men are better drivers
here's why he's wrong here's why he's
right and you have to go and like become
this you know get do a doctoral thesis
you know on a 30-second buzz clip that
is just absolute horseshit but it takes
that long to refute that [ __ ] and so
when when i go in and i say you know
what it's not even so much about like
insurance rates so you want to talk
about safer drivers well let's go look
at the numbers here there are more men
on the road than there are women there
are more professional drivers there's
more long distance truckers there's more
people who are driving for a living who
are men than there are women so does
that defuse the the insurance rates for
women being safer drivers so you can go
into th that level of detail and refute
all that [ __ ] that hassan was coming at
tape for and but but at the end of the
day
nobody cares you know right and that's
not i mean truly when he's on top of
that who cares truly what he was just
saying is if you asked a bunch of men i
mean i could sit here and say if you go
and ask a bunch of women they're all
going to say they're the better drivers
right that's what that's what you're
going to get from women they're going to
say well i'm a better job car drivers
there's more professional drivers
there's more sports drivers so it's you
can you can't make that statement
without taking it because that's one
data point right one data point is well
women have lower insurance premiums so
therefore they're the safer drivers well
yeah but that's not what he's saying
here whatsoever you could take that as a
data point but we got to take that in
consideration with there's more
long-haul truckers there's more nascar
drivers there's more f1 drivers there's
more i don't know sprint car drivers
whatever you want to put it out as i
could go and do that and diffuse the
numbers and just wiggle out of it
however you want to roll i did a whole
show on equal pay because i'm so tired
of that conversation just coming out
like a sticker you know women need to
get paid and i went through the
decisions women make the choices they
make how many hours you're actually in
the workplace i mean i really laid it
out for everyone because if we're gonna
have a debate
well and also if you're going to have a
debate about something again we keep
coming back to the same point there has
to be some foundation of fact involved
or it's just stupid and not worth my
time so i did a lot of digging on that
but that is another conversation on
equal pay that you have all the little
banners and the little stickers and none
of it is grounded in reality if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]